saving western civilization one childish
dick joke at a time
here they are your new heroes of the
imperium
mersh and royce lopez
yo how's everybody doing out there guys
uh revenge of the sis mike shelly royce
lopez
so anyway um do do like your governors
are gonna do this year guys
and do whatever you want go to cabo
fly people or just fly people in and
have big parties that's
that's what i would do that sounds like
fun actually i want to really go
over the top with it well i mean in
florida you really we can't get in
trouble
but um i don't know maybe we should
throw some kind of party in florida
and like just just to show off just to
flex on the rest of the country
you know what i mean get some good
footage of it like just
just make an open party where everybody
like around christmas time like not at
christmas because everybody's busy but
let's just have a big party
at some bar and just have everybody come
and have like [ __ ] christmas
decorations
and just flex on these fools i mean i'm
fine with that
ever just everyone running around
drinking licking each other's faces and
[ __ ]
let's show these mothers well
um this one's a
couple things in this video that i want
to cover but this is a quick two minute
video check this out
[Music]
a fox news alert a huge demonstration
outside a bar
in staten island new york and it
continues tonight the owner of that bar
was arrested
for publicly defying the lockdowns put
in place by the governor of that state
the bar owner spoke to us a few minutes
ago nearly 2 000 people showed up
outside his bar
to protest his arrest and as we said
many are still gathered there at this
hour we'll continue to keep an eye on
this
haven't seen anything like it before so
the bar owner and
i i'll go back to that video in a second
but the barnard declared him
declared his land a sovereign land
and he wouldn't shut down he kept it
open i swear to god
you mean to tell me somebody in staten
island new york went
sovereign citizen yeah like it's you
know you hear about this [ __ ] in like
arkansas
or like oklahoma there'll be some bar
owner that's like
no under the the act of
1687 i'm allowed and you're like what
but a new yorker went sob sit
this is great this is two days ago in
front of his bar
hey yo am i being detained
this is them arresting him because he
wouldn't shut down
were they're literally arresting
somebody for not shutting down
hey oh i don't consider myself a legal
subject of the united states of america
what am i being detained over there
excuse me sir license and registration
please
[Laughter]
oh
it's not just [ __ ] hillbillies
anymore guys people are getting pissed
hey listen all i'm saying is is this all
right
i don't recognize your legal authority
to come in here and to see him i'm a
sovereign citizen
i got my own flag i got my own thing
over here
he says i want to see i want to see
staten island's offset trial
well right after shortly before this
they were throwing rocks at the green
goblin and saying you messed for one of
us you messed with all of us
if look look everybody knows okay
that timothy didn't act alone okay he
didn't exist in a vacuum
that's what i'm saying he took a lot of
fbi
dudes in his [ __ ] ear oh you should
be the federal building
look let me tell you something there's
no bigger
domestic terrorist organization than the
fbi
and that's real he's just going full
full spurred with it
he's getting in the van he's going hey
oh oh reeds
over here and where am i where are my
thin blue line people at when this is
happening where are you guys at
huh they're uh resting oh okay i didn't
realize that putting him in handcuffs
for
opening up his business that's where
they're at
wait how did we find ourselves here hey
i'm at a drunk driving checkpoint
but i'm just gonna slide my papers
through i got my papers taped up to my
window
[Laughter]
gotta get the lighting on
[Music]
feels like a blair witch project but you
know staten island was scarier
yeah we want to make sure the people
that live on garbage island are safe
it's not a nice place
staten island gets zero respect from
anybody it's really funny
like staten island only exists so that
long island people have something to
[ __ ] on oh yeah you know what i mean
like
like everybody will be picking on long
island and staten island will be like
yeah you [ __ ] trash in long island be
like hey
hey get a [ __ ] hold of yourself your
staten island
knock it off
he really thought that just painting
autonomous zone and orange
like it's a [ __ ] laser tag place well
he was well like what
i guess from what i'm from when i
referenced he was basically
making fun of the chaz or making fun of
like the oh okay that's
he was doing it as like hey i'm just
like jazz bro leave me alone that's what
he was doing
max public house we got scott lebano
over here it's disgusting
i'll tell you what i've got guarantee
you if i was one of those moments you
wouldn't be here closing me down
if i was kicking in some sneaker store
that put their
they put their lives on the line to stay
open and prove a point and nobody's
backing them the [ __ ] up
except a handful of us get the [ __ ] down
here
bro heroes bro they put their life on
the line dude bro they died in the
towers
well they're alive well let me just
meant in general cops are those ghost
cops no they're not
oh my god no royce staten island has
ghost cops no they're not
holy [ __ ] i am terrified
first of all rita you act like you've
never seen the documentary ghostbusters
before you're right i apologize
what if you're the only guy on the
planet never saw that i apologize
but that's what they'll always throw in
your face in new york like when they go
like
you guys are being fascist now and
they're like hey hey hey
policeman died in the towers
back open for business chinese back off
their business
the kids are back i know that's why i
called that the
china virus there's a real lady i know
what i'm doing
they're doing well danny's getting ready
they're trying
we got your back look guys wearing a
thin blue line mask this i'm glad this
is happening to this guy by the way
this guy's the most embarrassing i'm not
i'm not glad that it's happened to the
bartender
from everything i've seen the guy who
kept the bar open is actually
pretty cool dude who's saying [ __ ]
everybody [ __ ] you guys i'm gonna do
what i want but this guy
we got your back why don't you got my
back this guy is a modern art piece
right here
don't have your back that's why i've
always said stop with the
thin blue line [ __ ] stop pandering to
them they don't have your back
and by the way i'm not a person that's
[ __ ] like defund the police i'm not i
don't [ __ ] on cops all the time when
they do bat [ __ ] i do obviously
and when they do good [ __ ] i praise them
but this whole making of religion around
it is dumb i mean you have a thin blue
line mask on
and they're not going to back you
because
they want their jobs so they're not
gonna they're not backing you i'm also
gonna say this
this is the same like the right wing and
the left wing
both have stockholm syndrome and and
with the left you saw when the blm [ __ ]
was going on remember the guys that had
the rocks thrown through the window and
they're like we're on your side
well we have our own version of that
with the bootlickers
and that's exact this guy is the same
person on the other end that those kids
were when they got the rocks thrown
through their window he's going put them
on your side over here and they're like
they're not on your [ __ ] side they're
in it for a paycheck
and a pension and if their paycheck and
pension
comes at the cost of making sure you
can't have your paycheck and pension
guess what guess what's going to happen
and it's not even i'm not even saying
that the police
that show up to work and do this and
collect their pension are evil
they're not this is the way this is the
human condition
like if if we didn't build cathedrals
and build like
modern architecture in the industrial
revolution we'd still be out comp
competing over like saber-toothed tigers
and [ __ ] and guess what
you'd cut somebody's throat out there in
the jungle to take their food that's
just how human beings are
so it's it's ingrained in us i'll throw
three or four of you all into a [ __ ]
volcano i'm sorry
it's most humans are cowardly volcanoes
in florida
not yet you're right good point go to
yellowstone they'll be once again
please don't even say that bro in 20
times i know the [ __ ] is one good point
i'll tell you what's wrong with you
of all years royce goes hey at least we
don't have any volcanoes swallowing
florida it's like
no don't say that but yeah like that's
that's just how humans are
so i'm not even mad at these cops
necessarily but
it makes me laugh when you see the guy
with the thin blue line mask going babe
but we're
on the same side over hey we're all
people right oh
and that's like no they're cops they're
not people no no
this this is the moment where you go oh
my god we have to stop having their back
they clearly don't have ours
you know when you should have somebody
you should never always have anybody's
back
you know when you should have people's
back when they're right
that's when you should have somebody's
back right like this
there is a certain element all right if
i if we go into a bar right now and i
just grab some
dude's girlfriend's titties right and
then i tuck an asp beating
i don't expect royce to really step in
and try to help me like
were they nice titties that's all you
care about is if they were
good tears you'd be like all right fine
they were nice titties i'll get your
back
but he says sometimes you gotta learn a
lesson in life you just let's
sometimes you go i i can't have your
back here because you just committed
sexual assault in a bar
so it's this guy i'll get you out of
here safely but if you're expecting me
to fight these dudes with you
you committed a sexual assault well
she's
right tell your partner with your
supervisors and your union officials and
you they're not going to take oh my god
i love you
hey hey larry david they're not gonna
take it up with any of these people you
[ __ ]
i'm gonna go speak to the police unit
you know that group that notoriously is
known
for for serving justice to police
officers
that might be the fight he might be
better than mass guy
yeah i'm gonna go to the organization
that's in charge of protecting and
shielding you from the crimes you commit
uh that doesn't sound like a good plan
sir get on the right side
you're on the wrong side of this you're
supposed to be protecting the public
and they're going to get yesterday you
know what i think i think you teachers
don't work enough
i think you teachers should have to work
in the summertime too so i'm going to go
to the teachers unions
and i'm going to tell them i want them
working in the summertime
this guy is is very juicy
he's italian we always have your back
remember that we always have your
back
with your supervisors and your union
officials and you get on the right side
uh-huh why isn't he wearing a green hat
he looks familiar
on the wrong side of this yeah he i told
you who he's larry david
no but he looks like an actual comedian
larry david's an actual comedian
i mean like a like a comedian not
would be well known is what i'm saying
well people know that somebody at like a
barry ribs level
got it someone that's bob levy's friend
exac exactly
somebody on that level i can't remember
who it is but he reminds me of somebody
inside of this you're supposed to be
protecting the public you are hurting
the public
you are protecting the dictators in the
governor's mansion yeah i know i
understand what you're saying sir
sir i understand what you're saying but
uh i don't care
yeah uh sir this guy's standing in front
that's not a cop
they don't realize get on the right side
they don't feel like sir
sir i'm gonna have to ask you to stand
back there's this badge i just want to
explain to you sarah okay that i have a
three-year-old daughter
okay and i have to pay for a house in
linwood and it's very expensive
so uh if i have to face
i will do so to protect my pension
i mean seriously
where's my sandwich there goes the
bartender that now can't work tonight
they gave you tickets too really
they gave her they gave them a bartender
they gave them take
i guess because you're not supposed to
be there they gave the bartender a
ticket
video of the summer how much is the
ticket
how many happening right now they gave
them two three
four one everybody four they gave them
four tickets
five you got five summoners yeah
everyone's here
this is this is how community goes thank
you said it was up to a thousand dollars
the bartender got a
thousand dollars worth of tickets
which is pretty not shocking when you
think about new york tickets
they're insane these people are trying
to give her money yes which by the way
you're not you're not fixing first of
all you [ __ ] simps
stop it stop going so cause if that
let's be honest if that was just some
dude you probably wouldn't be
breaking out the cash as quickly second
of all you're not
you're not gonna win any [ __ ] war of
ideas by paying the fines
the word of ideas you just came up with
that that's really cool you should make
a whole network and a dark web about it
i hate you what but you're not gonna
you're you're not going
to get anywhere by like if anything what
you should say is like if you're going
to be a simp for this chick you should
go
you know what let's get you an attorney
and let's fight this thing to the
[ __ ] buck there's already a guy there
but that but that's
there's no the whole oh yeah no we'll
just pay the fines for you darling okay
so the state learns nothing then
well but this marianne person's happy
because her realty thing's getting a
nice plug
it's good for her right oh man which
also now
now that made me think of also how many
things are shut down next to it because
of
because of they're being shut down how
many of these this ladies probably has a
bunch of these signs up
this girl was in there she's collecting
donations she's a bartender in the place
how much is the total on the summons
wait wait wait wait wait wait five
thousand dollars
yeah well she's a woman in their sims so
i'm going to go with 3 500.
no she actually said she don't she they
try to give her money and she wouldn't
take it
oh well it's good for her i mean she
didn't take the money for going to work
[Applause]
but hey where's your thin blue line huh
bad blue line blue line they're gonna
protect you
hey guys by the way if cops are gonna do
this over covet you know what they're
gonna do when they come to tell you to
take your [ __ ] guns you know what's
gonna happen
hey by the way i just did i don't know
if maybe you just didn't hear me earlier
but uh but we're on your side you know
that right
here's a ticket but i didn't even do
anything i wasn't even in the bar
here's a ticket for talking back but i
just i didn't but i didn't here's
another ticket
here's another ticket for being on our
side should i just leave then
yeah fine but there's going to be a
ticket to the leaving ticket
hits new york in a nutshell in new york
am i wrong
[Laughter]
are you ashamed of yourself
holy [ __ ] i'm waiting for somebody to
say you know my uncle was a cop on 9 11.
you know what's coming
somebody going to work how proud of you
this is insane
whoa whoa oh uh oh
you're [ __ ] animal you know what i
like i'll be honest out of everybody
there i like her though
i did kind of like her staten island
people are trashy get animal i'll [ __ ]
you
up they will fist fight yeah cops
outside of a bar
yeah that's disgusting
she just works here [ __ ] disgusting
but you know what it is to give a five
thousand dollar fine to an
employee not even the owner right an
employee of a business
yeah i mean the only time you should
really be allowed to do that is if they
serve
like underage people no no of course of
course but yeah there's there's no but
just for going
for going to work
we're staying
just for being their attorney they gave
me something
wait wait wait they gave the attorney so
what so now he can't he can't
he can't represent them
dude they give three summon to the
attorney
also can i add this guy's an attorney
staten island attorney hold on hey hey
hey let's let's you know do with
reporters and how they look depending on
whether
he's staten island hey if anybody hurt
their ankles during this entire whole
affair please
contact me we're all suing the nypd this
guy had two options become an attorney
or go after daredevil
those were his two options and he picked
the turn
what do you want him to do just picture
the code on him
of course
[Laughter]
i'm telling you right now i was so
pissed off
i was so pissed off i almost knocked out
that cop
like i did bart gunn brawl for all it's
not him no
come on man you know i was so mad that i
ate the turnbuckle
george the animal steel reference nice
[Laughter]
you know so then so then i started
attacking the cop
right but then he did the right sequence
and he hit me in the stomach
and then i was stunned and then he was
able to hit me in the face repeatedly
that's king hippo oh okay
does this man look like royalty to you
oh [ __ ] him completely polite to him
what a violation
i was just here to make sure everything
was peaceful and calm i was on my way to
my son's bed
then i realized that was just staten
island i realized it was this complete
waste of time i don't know what i was
thinking
honestly this place is so [ __ ] up i
wasn't sure what bart was
i mean honestly it's staten island
people get stabbed at baptisms around
here
it's [ __ ] wild and when i got a call
that the sheriffs were coming in
i came by can i just make a comment here
too sure can we all agree
good camera oh great camera this is
where we're filming dudes
i don't know who's filming what camera
this is but can we get a can we get a
yeah can the person let us know what
kind of camera they're using that's nice
because it's auto focused on him good
but the
even the blurry stuff behind him looks
good like this looks like a real legit
documentary or something good for him
and i said guys be respectful be
cooperative
and be and make sure and then i realized
again uh that i was in staten island and
i was really just
wasting my breath
after they gave me the summit says i was
in there for an hour right now
i'm in there for an hour danny's in
there by
and here he is being arrested
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
i also want to say something about this
situation
you know we always see these videos
there's like some small town texas bar
owner
it's this guy or it's that guy this
guy's going to new york
jail yeah he is he's going to central
booking
gen pop in a new york city jail for
opening up a bar
we always talk about the fines and the
you know the fact that
just by principle alone these rules are
draconian
but think about the actual impact of
like it's the holiday season you know
it's a couple weeks till christmas you
got shopping to do
you'll be out on bond in the morning but
like that's not the point like you got
to spend the night in a new york city
like i've i've been to jail before but
nothing like a new york city jail
that's miserable that's a that's a
miserable thing to do to somebody
like there's a reason why back in the
day cops would let you slide on [ __ ]
because they genuinely had some flex
back then
and they genuinely would consider do i
really want to stick this guy in [ __ ]
jets
they like they they had a an idea of
what that process
was so they go you know what i don't
want to [ __ ] you over too bad look do me
a favor i know your license is suspended
i should technically arrest you
but it looks like it's it was suspended
two days ago
so look just whatever go get your [ __ ]
straightened out merry christmas and you
go wow man thank you
they don't do that anymore like now
they're just arresting a guy for opening
up his bar
they gave this poor bartender five
thousand dollars in fines
and again this guy has to spend the
night in a new york jail like that's
shitty somebody's pointing out that's
not nypd that's the sheriff's which it
is it is sheriff's because
it says sheriff's on the thing nypd is
worse
when it comes to this stuff i mean i
don't know maybe that's what your point
was but in terms of enforcing these
rules nypd is worse
there is no sheriff's jail correct
you're going to the same jail it doesn't
matter who the [ __ ] like you know what i
mean it could be a [ __ ] security
guard that arrests you
you're going to the same jail you're
still going to either the tombs
or you're going to central booking or
you're going to one of those really
shitty jail like it doesn't matter who
arrests you
you're still going to the same spot same
thing here in florida you can get
arrested by
uh the sheriff's you can get arrested by
a local pd or you can get arrested by
florida highway patrol
guess where you're going polk county
jail there's just this only
there's one place they drop off the
trash so yeah this is this is [ __ ] man
by the way that female detective want to
see her without the mask
oh
[Music]
hey we back you guys look at my mask but
the thing is man that means a lot of
these people are gonna have to get
better attorneys in this big [ __ ]
grease ball cause
pete they're gonna have to get some
dudes that are in deep that are that can
fight because i mean and when i say
fight i don't just mean fight like the
constitutional
you know this is wrong and all that [ __ ]
i mean
i mean to get a lawyer that can fight
them
on every procedural misstep
that they make because these cops are
flustered right now they don't you know
let's be honest they'll do this because
they'll protect their pensions but a lot
of them really don't want to be doing
this a lot of them would rather just be
standing around rockefeller center
doing nothing this isn't fun for the
cops either but they'll do what they're
told
so that means they're flustered they're
frazzled so you need to get one of those
lawyers that's like okay and did you
read them their miranda rights
and did you notify their attorney where
you were taking them and did you do like
you need a lawyer like that who's gonna
really just
nitpick the state and try to [ __ ] them
because
that's all you can do how can they do
that
let them find out let them find out
killer
cuomo taking them to the sheriff's
office hey guys
guys
the
[Music]
[Music]
staten island this is them being
respectful
hey [ __ ] show some [ __ ] respect
over hey
[ __ ] you so this order
simply says this order simply says
excuse me that we will no longer be
allowing spider-man to operate in this
city
that they need to cease and desist
nowhere here is there an arrest warrant
and nowhere hears anything about
arresting anyone so you break the
[ __ ]
on that private property so so i'll ask
you don't have to ask
you don't have to answer my name is
andrew lanza i'm the senator who
represents this area
former prosecutor uh-oh on behalf of my
constituents thank you andy
i would just like to have an answer why
was he arrested uh-oh
hold on whoa wait a second can i just
okay hold on now it's getting a little
different here
i'd like to point out to those of you
that aren't familiar with new york
um that's
staten island is a very small
neighborhood yeah
like i really genuinely feel like the
senator is somewhere in the area close
enough that he's like
the hell's going on down there and just
walked over there
because it's that like staten island's a
small [ __ ] neighborhood dude
he even put his mask on with the seal of
his city it's it's [ __ ] he did
you know what good for him honestly i
mean i i'll also know that he's doing it
because he wants votes when he gets to
come i guess
but still it is nice to see a senator
show up but that's the only reason
they're going to do it anyway
you're right you're right you know but
good i'm glad he's doing the right thing
and honestly he's probably a no mass guy
he probably had to go find that message
keeps falling down under his nose did
you see but you could tell you probably
had to go god damn it i never wear that
thing but i can't go out there without
it because i'm gonna look bad in the
in the [ __ ] in the sound bite later
so he went grabbed his mask
i was told you would tell me why he was
arrested and now i'm asking for that
answer transparency
transparency
okay shut up the center can handle this
without you buddy i really hate this
no i understand i understand that he's
mad and i mean i'm mad too but
but once the senator shows up you're
like
yeah that's when you sit back and go
dope all right we got a senator here
you have to give an answer
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you just took out one of our
constituents one of our neighbors yeah a
business owner
in handcuffs i asked why you handed this
to me
this piece of paper does not authorize
your arrest if there was some other
reason why you were arrested i trespass
them i'd like to know what that is
but you can't trespass him is his pr
it's his property
you can't trespass somebody on their own
property yeah that's not how it works
well that's that's what the guy said
right so i'll tell you what happened
here
this scene was going on this [ __ ] was
[ __ ] going crazy but ever this thing
was going nuts
and somebody from the governor's office
maybe como himself was like you'll rest
that gay
we're gonna show him you'll rest that
gay because this guy from what i've been
reading
has been defined the governor's order
openly saying i'm not going to shut this
no i won't do it i won't do it i won't
do it so what they're doing now is
making an example of him
and uh that was somebody now that the
senators have a very good point there
isn't an arrest warrant nowhere in the
order to say you could arrest
people you could find people it does say
that in the emergency order it does but
also you could arrest people
can someone answer or no who's the
senior officer here they trespass no
people who's just saying you're upset
so nobody can speak with
by the way there's no senior officer
there for these things they don't send
senior officers okay
they send whoever is wearing the [ __ ]
the midnight shift yeah stop using lingo
you learned on tv shows hey where's the
lt
i want to speak to the shut up you're
just a [ __ ] construction worker from
staten island
shut up
i'm not threatening you like the
senators
[Music]
his attorney is right here
honestly right now i'm sorry but the
most helpful thing you could do is let
the attorney
and the senator handle this can we agree
that that would now be the best course
of action here
um
i don't ever want to hear people say
that long islanders are the worst new
yorkers ever again
i never want to hear that again
all the employees got big fines uh
it's really crazy to see that patent for
monaki became an attorney you know
that's pretty cool
warning no trespass you cannot you could
enter this property only if you have
the owners or legal occupants written
verbal permission or you are a u.s mail
carrier commercial or
delivery service or you're responding to
a medical fire emergency or you possess
valid constitutional fourth amendment
warrants signed by a judge
with proper jurisdiction showing a
probable cause
and the specific place and things to be
searched all other persons are excluded
the right
to exclude anyone even government or law
enforcement is a fundamental
constitution blah blah blah so they put
that sign up
but now that you're here now that i see
you have the power
why are you sticking around because the
democrats passed a year and a half ago
okay
stop look i get it i understand so let's
see i'm just gonna so
you people that are here now you better
stick around for this kid
to stick up for them in their business
yes so hey who's this guy
is he an attorney i would assume that he
is
tomorrow night at six o'clock i want the
[ __ ] street
packed with people who are you island
boys i i don't know who this guy is
i i don't know who this guy is is this
your big spartacus moment i hate people
like this okay so here's the center
this this this actually i wanted to god
that's a good camera yeah
and they came out and he was in
handcuffs and he's been taken away
i asked the sheriffs for an explanation
i think the community is entitled to one
okay first off that's john taffer the
mask is not hiding it
that's john taffer he was doing a bar
rescue and he's mad now because
he's that all his footage is useful now
he can't rescue the bar anymore
again that's how it works in america
when the government cards someone off
um i was told they would give me an
explanation
i told them who i was that i was the
senator representing this area
i'm also by the way former prosecutor i
know my way around the law a little bit
and they provided this to me as the
explanation for
hauling them out in handcuffs now what
this is
is an order for the closure of this
establishment
this is not an arrest warrant in fact
there's nothing here
that speaks to whether or not anyone
what somebody says i'm wrong that's
actually nick apollo
and arrested so again i posed the
question
and i understand that things are a bit
volatile and they might not want to
answer
here at this forum but at the same time
i think at some point
the people of staten island deserve to
have an answer
with respect to why one of our neighbors
was carted off
and handcuffed because como [ __ ]
said so there's nothing there's there's
no other hidden secret
because como [ __ ] said so yeah that's
why
there's not gonna be much recourse here
until until it becomes just a national
battle
until until [ __ ] like stop
getting voted
go to vote it in this isn't gonna
nothing's gonna work well this was on
december 1st apparently every night
large crowds of supporters
have been showing up in front of it and
def to def
and defied the covert restroom holy [ __ ]
do you want to see how much you okay
i hadn't seen this so this is this is
last night you want to see what this
place looks like last night
the gran city section of the staten
island bar turned out last night wow
it's almost like
a shutdown police say the bar located in
a coveted hot spot repeatedly defied
restrictions cbs 2's john diaz joins us
live from the grant city section of
staten island with more this morning
john
yeah good morning chris good morning
marion after showing up in large numbers
last night protesters have
since left they left late last night but
this morning though yeah it's six in the
morning they're not gonna be there at
six in the morning you take a look right
here behind me
uh you could see that there are still
notices hung up here on this bar
stating that a partial vacate order only
allowing the owner inside and emergency
responders now the new york city
but you arrested the owner sheriff
office says there were no arrests last
night
and no one was issued a summons but
there was an arrest
we saw the man get arrested no it's just
the day after this is the day after
so maybe there were nobody was arrested
the day after oh you okay you're right
your part two flew over what looks like
a major block party on staten island
yeah it's almost like uh
it's very similar to the streisand
effect it's almost like
what you should have done was just
nothing and nobody would have shown up
and there's no big crowd you see how
that works it's almost like you should
just let a couple of bar flies
take up space on a stool and drink some
people just want to do that
and i can tell you this the kind of
people that are hanging out in a staten
island bar on a weeknight
are not the kind of people that care if
they die no yeah so
let them alone night but instead it was
a large protest
most people without masks on hundreds
standing shoulder to shoulder
with american flags and political signs
demanding
change in the area demonstrating in
front of new york city sheriff's
officers
who were don't show up
with your trump stuff i cannot stress
this
enough don't and it's not it's it's not
it's not me [ __ ] on trump i'm not
[ __ ] on trump
but the moment that people start showing
up with their trump stuff
then all the media is gonna go oh it's
just a political thing it's a bunch of
trump this should be
angry people being mad at the government
but they don't it shouldn't be a
i know it shouldn't be a political party
that is mad at the government it should
be people
that are mad that they're not allowed to
go to go into a business this isn't
about trump
this isn't about biden this isn't a
political rally
this is about them arresting somebody
for opening their bar
without with any without any law saying
that they could
this is what this is about the trump
2020
and the trump flags in this situation
don't do anything
they don't care they don't listen they
don't care it's a cult
it became a cult you just showed that
music video yesterday
that's the mentality of these people
they don't [ __ ] care
which is why i got so sick of being a
part of these movements
because nobody really gives a [ __ ] they
just want to [ __ ] advertise their
[ __ ] all day but
but here but he put no thought into it
but here's the truth when it comes to
stuff like this too right
in the real [ __ ] world where people
stop playing by the rules and get real
what was it what was the mtv thing um
[Music]
start being realistic so whatever
whatever in the real world road rules
but the real world there's there would
probably there's probably a lot of
people that didn't vote for trump a lot
of people that didn't vote
even people that voted for biden that
are actually mad at this
right we're like oh you know i voted for
biden because of this but not because of
that whatever
but now you start you start losing
people that are
you want as many people as possible
regardless of their political
affiliation to be there with you and be
[ __ ] pissed
this can't be just can't be a [ __ ]
republican democrat thing this has to be
a taking people's freedoms
versus not because you were bringing up
too like there was a lot of [ __ ]
people that were all scared of
chronovirus you're talking about your
friends in tampa in the service industry
that are now like they can't shut down
again i need my job
there's a lot of liberals there's a lot
of bernie bros now that are like yeah
like [ __ ] bernie okay i get it but i
have to go to work i get what you're
saying royce but how then how do i own
the libs
not everything is about owning no but
how do i own you don't have to
like i get i understand what you're
saying
but just hear me out on this how do i
oh people stop getting polite that's
what it was sorry that's what it is but
no but like i
get where you're coming from and like
freedom and constitution and all that
it's whatever
but like how do i trigger snowflakes
you don't have to the [ __ ] i don't no
that's what this is all about it's not
about culture war dude
no it's not about that do you understand
why i hate some
a lot of trump people now that's why
because
because neither side i've learned in the
last four years
neither side actually cares
everyone just wants to make their point
and shout over everybody
and trigger snowflakes
guarding the front of mac's public house
it's a bar and restaurant that was
forced to close
when its owners refused to stop indoor
dining in an
orange zone after several orange zones
manager
hey you know i want to apologize mike
for everything i said before in this
past hour
it was an orange zone i wasn't aware
because if i would have known who gives
a [ __ ] what zone it was in
i'm so sick of these zones getting but
as long as it wasn't purple or saturday
night
because i'm not [ __ ] around you're
not messing around with those no it's
why would you go to anywhere in the
purple and red zones it's illegal
oh you're right if you go through that
magical barrier that's it you get
arrested by the government
and damien's had a good point he says it
was two blocks away from open
restaurants so two blocks away was a
different zone and they were allowed to
have restaurants open
for defying the order they're just
trying to support their family the
jackals
orange zone bad
family kevin smith was mixed in with a
group of supporters kevin smith looks
worse now
by the way somebody in the chat says
nobody says snowflakes anymore jesus
christ
someone doesn't have a twitter account i
dare you to
oh by the way you don't think anybody
says snowflakes anymore i haven't even
been to parlor
but i bet you if i went to parlor right
now and typed snowflake
into their [ __ ] search bar i'd be
here all day
so don't tell me nobody says that he
believes this enforcement is wrong
there's people doing heroin and
defecating on the subway
that's just in my house that's just my
wife
[Laughter]
is the virus a lot wait a minute there's
people doing heroin and defecating on
the floor then maybe they should have
shut that bar down
no not in the barn this oh drink in
staten island keith michelarny is the
owner and feels he is being stopped from
making money
i'm allowed to be inside my private
property i pay my rent
and with them paying my rent they're
saying right now i can't serve food and
i can't serve alcohol
however the guidelines for orange zone
areas allowed him to serve takeout
alcohol and outdoor diners
the area oh good outdoor dining [ __ ]
did you see that little tiny square have
you seen some of the outdoor stuff that
they're doing
some of the outstore stuff is resembling
um used to be a word for it
buildings yeah they built have you seen
those structures they're building
indoor outdoors outdoor is becoming
indoors
they're building actual structures that
are just like being what's the
difference there's no logic behind it i
don't understand it
yeah it has one of the highest covent
infection rates in the city
the zip code it's in is at 8.62 percent
oh 8.6
what's the death what's the death three
people oh
but this local business owner tells us
restrictions are
too tough it's not enough for someone
operating in new york city
we pay high city tax we pay high state
tax uh you know we pay high federal tax
again it's almost like you should
[ __ ] move
everybody else hey great value john
leguizamo why don't you just move
literally anywhere else
this is weird disease that new yorkers
have it's hpv a lot of people have it
it's not just new yorkers but it's it's
this i
i talk to new yorkers all the time like
my nephew finally just
broke away from this [ __ ] mind spell
that new york has over you
but every time i talk this is why i
always yell at you californians too
like not necessarily if you have kids
and they're in school and stuff but i
know
single people in california that always
tell me i can't afford to leave here
it's like yeah
that whole place is set up to make sure
you can never afford to leave
yeah you're right [ __ ] so the ponzi
scheme it's what i tell people in new
york and what i tell people in
california all the time
just leave like they go put put how do i
make the jobs don't pay as much down
there yes because everything's like a
fifth of the price
like you do you not understand math like
new york has the spell over people and
they go i can't leave this is my and
it's like
it's not that great a couple of months
in florida and you're gonna go
holy [ __ ] i actually have money in my
bank account you know what
i'm gonna take the day off of work i'm
gonna go to the beach like you could
just
dude i know this sounds nuts right but
like our parents used to do this back in
the day
if you live in florida you can actually
just take a day off of work
and go to the beach that's pretty dope
like you can afford to
even if you wait tables you can afford
to do that here
but these people in need they go it's
too expensive and it's like
they got to do something around here and
it's like or you
could leave like that's that is an
option these people in new york and
california are they remind me of people
that are in an abusive relationship and
you go
he's literally hitting you on a weekly
basis you have to leave him and they're
like
oh but i wouldn't know like remember the
dan cook bit but he's got all my cds and
his truck oh my i can't just leave all
those cds
that's how new yorkers think and it's
like just leave
capacity just to be able to even pay our
bills and pay our staff
that is why many supporters showed up at
a certain point
you know like people would go like
people on the left like to say
our body our choice but business owner
larry tajudin who works next to the bar
wonders why everyone can't come together
to slow the spread
why can't we just all be on one page
this that guy is the same
because because your laundromat is
allowed to be open you pieces [ __ ]
because you're [ __ ] that's the
business next door is a laundromat
because your laundromat is allowed to be
open you [ __ ] face
now some other business owners telling
us that they are aware of the increase
in cova cases
here in this area but they feel though
that their hands are tied
with little to no help they say from you
know local state and
federal authorities so
needs to give us more money we need we
need we need more
we need more handouts that's what you
want you know instead of the handout
things it's just you know open up
and you know what you can't just i mean
they do it anyway but you shouldn't i
say you can't because saying can't do
this is not true because they do it
you shouldn't just print money you
shouldn't just
print money to try to get yourself out
of this because that's how you have a
housing crisis that's why you have
a lot of financial crisis that's how you
have market crashes that's how people's
401ks disappear
you can't you can't just [ __ ] write
your check
write your write a check out of this
it's not how it works